Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P and this caller has
a question about the impact that the train
derailment may have on the 2024 election.
Speaker 2: They did it. So the situation in East
Palestine, Ohio. What do you think the political
ramifications will be for 2024? Does this make it
harder for Democrats to win Ohio? Because we are
in power right now and whatever happens will
get blamed on Democrats or the lack of things
that are going on now. Do you think that it'll
have political ramifications for 2024? Thanks.
Speaker 1: You know, I really don't.
I really don't. Now there's the truth,
and there's what you can spin. The truth
is that I don't know why Democrats would
be blamed for the train derailment, given that
what happened is that as far as we know right now,
the rail company did not install hot box detectors
as close together as they are recommended. And
as a result, they missed that. The train fire
appeared to have started 20 miles out of East
Palestine. That has nothing directly to do with
Democrats specifically. It generally has to do
with under regulation. The governor of Ohio is a
Republican. Ohio is basically run by Republicans.
But it also isn't clear that it's necessarily
an Ohio thing. But the truth of the matter is,
it would be really weird to blame certainly
Biden if he's the Democratic candidate in 2024
for the train derailment. Train derailments are
sadly quite common. Fortunately, they've also
declined in frequency over time. Now, Ohio hasn't
gone for Democrats since 2012 and 2008. In 2016,
Trump won Ohio and won the presidency in 2020.
Trump won Ohio but lost the presidency. I don't
believe that the Ohio 2024 results are going
to hinge on the train derailment in particular.
Not only because it doesn't
make sense that they would,
but in particular because voters have a
relatively short memory. And I just don't
think it's going to be something Ohio voters are
going to decide on. But if you disagree with me,
let me know in the comments. We have a fantastic
bonus show for you today. We're going to talk
about Putin bailing on the New START treaty.
We are going to talk about critics rejecting
changes to Roald Dahl's books as censorship.
And I will tell you my position on that. And
we will talk a little bit about Project Veritas
founder James O'Keefe out at his organization,
partially because of multiple harassment claims,
as I understand it. All of those stories and more
will be on today's bonus show. Oh, the.
Speaker 3: Bonus show where you want to
make money. Sure. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Help us make a little money on
the bonus show. We call it funding independent
media. You can sign up at join Packman dot
com. This gets you instant access to the
bonus show. It funds all of the work we do. And
you get the Daily Show without commercials hours
before everybody else. You can sign up at join
Packman dot com. You can use the discount code. 24
starts now. And boy has it ever. I look
forward to seeing you on today's program.